this is what hazardous air pollution
looks like
the 20 million residents of New Delhi
are breathing smog
some of the city's most famous sites Now
hidden in some areas levels of pollution
are nearly 40 times the maximum
recommended by the World Health
Organization
I feel a shortage of oxygen and the
plants and trees are dying there's no
Greenery and the pollution level is very
high the government's asking people to
stay inside
diesel cars and trucks are banned from
entering the capital
construction has been stopped and some
factories closed
the governments announced primary
schools will be shut from Saturday
following calls from parents and other
groups
when we wake up in the morning we feel
that we should not send our children to
school the conditions are so bad that
when we go to our balcony we feel
difficulty in breathing
New Delhi is the world's most polluted
capital
one study found more than 17 000 deaths
in 2019 were linked to air pollution
every winter it's blanketed in smog as
cold heavy air traps dust and pollution
another major cause is crop burning by
farmers in the neighboring states of
Punjab and haryana a problem that's
often politicized with opposition
parties seizing on who is to blame
the issue of stubble burning can be
resolved by assisting the farmers not by
cussing them the central government in
India is ruling bharatiya janata party
should apologize to the farmers instead
of blaming them they should also
apologize to the residents of Delhi
the chief Ministers of Punjab and Delhi
say they're doing all they can to tackle
pollution but are calling on federal and
state governments to work together
prime minister Narendra Modi has said
India will aim to stop emitting
greenhouse gases by 2070. that's two
decades later than a goal adopted by the
U.S and at least 10 years later than
China
back in the city this smog is expected
to last for days and more emergency
measures are planned but without major
changes the millions of people who live
there will have little choice but to
adapt to what's fast becoming a new
normal
Alexandra Byers Al Jazeera